I can make a pie from scratch
can you yeah it's one of mine one of my
hidden talents you layer out the dough
in the pot to let you know the preview
of the barrel you mix the dough then you
you greased the thing that I've never
had someone explain how to make a pie
well I kind of said you said it like it
was like this frozen you layer the did
your terminology terrific only you could
respond to pie banter with like a
yourself mentality it's a wonderful
thing it's a beautiful thing to do make
a meal for somebody deal with that
that's another side of me you can't yes
you don't even know me you've known me
for 10 years you have no idea who I am
he has this thing in his head oh yeah
yeah I'm putting you in a box yeah and
you're in that box thinking your loved
ones dessert that's great but with an
apron that says like
I have an apron I have an apron and it's
such look it is like an effeminate thing
I don't care it's great if you in it you
know you just you just go like this
let's keep going you go on to the next
part of it
it's what's it for yeah aprons can be
masculine like a welder that's a that's
a masculine apron I like a nice floral
pattern your whatever Inga neato you're
an enigma what because I'm a cap I know
you know it is you're not a good
listener maybe you know me for 10 years
you have no idea why I am it's all about
comedy with you and moving up the ladder
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this man asked about my baking skills
this little spot makes up for your 10
years of rudeness you're sadly mistaken
you mean if I had kept my mouth shut all
these rides two gigs and stuff I could
have instead of accelerating my career
picked up a few recipes
you could have I made the right choice
make homemade pasta pita I was just
joking Jesus you took it to a real place
there once are you saying my strategy
was okay yo buddy and the Germans are
back yes
[Music]